hello
everybody comment ça va aujourd'hui on
se parle d'un smartphone innovant d'un
smartphone intéressant d'un smartphone
comme les aime nos smartphones qui se
paye on se parle du Razer du raisin de
Motorola alors le réseau vous le
connaissez le réserve vous en avez déjà
entendu parler c'est aujourd'hui une
vidéo qui est réalisée en partenariat
avec Motorola pour venir vous présenter
le razeur 2022 l'évolution du Razer de
2019 parce que oui chez Motorola ils ont
l'innovation dans l'ADN alors je vais
vous montrer ça on va regarder on va
faire un tour complet on va regarder ce
Razer qui est juste là dans ma main vous
allez voir il a évolué il a changé il
raconte une nouvelle histoire une
histoire extrêmement intéressante vous
êtes prêt vous êtes prêts on y va c'est
comme
le réserve vous le connaissez c'est ce
téléphone mythique des années 2000 alors
je sais pas ça dépend quel âge vous avez
si vous êtes né dans les années 2000
peut-être vous ne le connaissez pas mais
il faut savoir que ce téléphone là
c'était juste un des must have un
téléphone qu'on voulait tout savoir le
smartphone avec le clapet qui se plie on
se la pété avec c'était très cool alors
je sais pas pour autant si vous
connaissez l'histoire de Motorola
Motorola c'est une boîte américaine qui
a été créée en 1928 autant vous dire que
ça fait un petit moment qu'ils existent
et on les a notamment connus pour la
téléphonie je vous dis une fois de plus
dans les années 2000 avec le Razer et
fatalement quand les technologies
d'écran qui se plie sont arrivés et bien
Motorola a travaillé sur sa copie revue
visiter et corrigée du Razer pour nous
proposer un smartphone à clapet avec un
grand écran version smartphone et ça
c'est chouette et Motorola revient en
2022 avec un Razer encore amélioré qui
est dans cette boîte enfin normalement
dans cette boîte parce qu'il est ici
d'ailleurs j'aime bien parce qu'ils ont
fait un truc hyper marrant ils sont dit
on peut pas proposer un smartphone
innovant avec un truc un peu classique
au niveau de l'unboxing donc vous avez
une boîte qui est très jolie qui vient
s'ouvrir le smartphone et là vous vous
en doutez j'ai déjà enlevé donc il y a
plus de smartphone ici ensuite vous
venez lever là et vous avez une petite
coque qui va être avec vous allez
pouvoir venir mettre sur le dessus et
une également regarder qui est
là-dessous sur le dessous pour venir
protéger votre Razer donc ça c'est cool
à l'intérieur on va retrouver un peu
dogue de quoi ouvrir le tiroir de carte
SIM OK et on a un bloc de charge qui
deviendra aujourd'hui en 2022 c'est un
bloc de chat c'est du 30 toit donc vous
venez le recharger en recharge rapide 30
watt cool et ici vous avez votre câble
qui est planqué juste là et là vous avez
quelques petites docs pour tout savoir
comment utiliser votre réserve mais vous
inquiétez pas si vous regardez cette
vidéo vous saurez tout donc regarder la
bien jusqu'au bout c'est marrant parce
qu'il me plein d'évolution chez Motorola
je sais pas si vous avez suivi mes
vidéos que j'ai fait depuis quelques
temps il y a eu un vrai changement une
évolution au niveau de la marque
notamment aussi au niveau des équipes
françaises avec de nouveaux produits qui
sont arrivés on a eu j'ai 50 on a eu g
100 et on a eu toute la gamme L30 L30
pro et je 30 fusion L3
ultra avec un capteur de 200 mégapixels
donc on va une fois de plus que
l'innovation est au cœur de la marque
chez Motorola et c'est pour ça qu'on
retrouve aujourd'hui un smartphone comme
celui-là avec de l'innovation avec le
Razer le Razer le Razer le Razer je sais
pas comment vous le dites RAZR Razer je
préfère dire Razer comme c'est une
marque américaine il y a un côté
American on y va c'est le Razer alors
regardez ce Razer ce Razer comme vous
voulez alors il est sympa parce que on
est une fois de plus dans l'idée l'ADN
du pliable de l'innovation avec une
charnière bulle d'eau charnière bulle
d'eau ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire
qu'ici en fait vous n'avez absolument
aucun jour l'écran vient complètement se
poser un contre l'autre et le truc qui
est vraiment très cool lorsque vous
l'ouvrez et ça c'est bien parce que on
le voit pas ailleurs c'est qu'en fait
vous ne sentez absolument pas la pliure
alors on la sent un petit point très
honnêtement mais par rapport à ce qu'on
a pu voir ici voyez la pliure on la voit
quasiment pas et pour autant elle existe
bien là et c'est l'intérêt de cette
charnière c'est comme il vient se plier
là voyez il y a pas de coupe nette et ça
vous emmène une partie un peu plus large
ce qui fait que ça vient pas la plier
vous voyez et donc tout l'intérêt qu'on
a ici au niveau de charnière et bien
c'est que lorsque vous venez passer
votre doigt ici il y a pas de pliure
donc ça c'est un premier point très très
positif et très très cool ensuite ce
Razer il a une vraie mise à jour par
rapport au Razer de 2019 je sais pas si
vous vous souvenez les réserves 2019 il
avait un grand menton il avait surtout
une très grande encoche ici et la
Motorola est vraiment venu retravailler
sa copie avec un menton qui a disparu
donc on a effectivement un tout petit
menton mais minuscule donc ça c'est bien
on a très très belle équilibre de
symétrie entre le haut et le bas là où
on a vu une grande encoche avant on
retrouve un point son sur le haut qui
fonctionne et qui est plutôt bien
intégré donc ça c'est cool on va
retrouver juste là un bouton pour venir
l'allumer les teintes qu'il faut office
de capteur d'empreinte digitale donc il
le déverrouille très facilement que vous
utilisez l'écran externe ou l'écran
interne ça marche dans les deux cas et
je vais vous montrer cet écran externe
dans quelques instants vous allez voir
il est extrêmement intéressant nouveauté
également vous avez un double module
photo alors qu'avant vous en aviez qu'un
seul donc on vient vraiment augmenter
significativement l'expérience et une
fois de plus je vais vous dire dans
quelques instants avec un capteur de 50
mégapixels un smartphone qui est plus
compact qui se tient bien dans la main
et qui est franchement très jolie qui
est disponible dans une seule couleur
alors ici c'est le noir avec un côté mat
à l'arrière oui ce petit noir mat où on
voit la marque le logo qui est très
élégant et à l'avant on retrouve un
écran alors là je peux venir vous parler
comme ça directement dans l'écran parce
que oui vous le voyez je peux utiliser
ma caméra directement là ça c'est cool
là c'est un écran de 2,7 pouces un écran
tactile alors écran tactile il est très
cool parce qu'en fait il est pas gadget
il est grand il est très grand il est
beaucoup plus grand que ce qu'on
retrouve d'ailleurs à la concurrence et
le truc qui est intéressant c'est qu'il
y a de vrai beaux usages ici je vous
montre vous venez sur le côté vous avez
des raccourcis au niveau de vos
applications ça c'est cool vous avez
ensuite la météo on peut venir modifier
à l'ordre des widgets si on le souhaite
là j'ai mis la météo là je vous mets des
petits raccourcis ça peut être le
clavier numérique pour venir passer un
coup de fil si on le souhaite on peut
dire directement le taper d'ici ça c'est
plutôt cool vous avez également un petit
raccourci pour venir envoyer un message
envoyer un petit message là donc ça
c'est très très cool ensuite je vais
avoir ici mon agenda que je n'ai pas
encore synchronisé je peux venir gérer
mes différents panneaux regardez je
clique sur Gérer les panneaux et là je
peux venir les moduler si par exemple je
veux venir passer la communication avant
la météo je laisse appuyer je la glisse
là et c'est extrêmement simple et
ensuite j'appuie là et je valide de la
même manière de l'autre côté je vais
avoir l'appareil photo donc là je peux
venir déclencher me voir directement
alors je peux déclencher en appuyant
directement sur l'écran ça déclenche en
appuyant sur le bouton volume sur le
côté là vous voyez j'appuie là et ça
déclenche également de la photo mais
également de la vidéo vidéo ralentie
portrait-y accès à tout donc je trouve
que d'un point de vue expérience ici que
parentiel logiciel ils ont bien bossé
c'est très fluide l'écran et de qualité
on appuie ça fonctionne donc là c'est
pareil j'appuie je lance une vidéo donc
vous voyez là je suis en train
d'enregistrer directement là ça c'est
plutôt cool et ensuite je peux venir si
je souhaite activer la cloche mettre un
minuteur hop là j'arrête
l'enregistrement vous voyez et j'ai
accès à mes informations ici tu peux
venir désactiver la stabilisation ou
l'activer ici je peux venir moduler le
nombre d'images par seconde en 30 ou en
60 images par seconde bref j'ai plein de
petits réglages sont très pratiques je
peux même venir garder hop là passer sur
l'ultra grand-angle ici donc là j'ai mon
ultra grand-angle hop là j'aurais pu là
et là j'ai mon capteur principal donc ça
je trouve ça extrêmement malin et plutôt
bien fait plutôt bien vu d'un point de
vue purement logiciel ensuite je reviens
de l'autre côté sur mon menu principal
je vais sur le haut j'ai accès à mes
paramètres donc là je vais régler ma
luminosité très facilement lampe de
poche mode avion accès à tous mes
réglages très facilement et je vais vers
le bas et j'ai accès ici à mes
notifications Tik Tok réseaux sociaux et
compagnie donc on voit qu'on a de vrais
usages ici de vraies informations et je
trouve ça vachement cool et même si je
veux venir regarder une vidéo YouTube
ici je peux venir le faire je clique sur
Youtube je me faisais une vidéo quelle
qu'elle soit hop là un petit
stupéflipollage là je balance et j'ai ma
vidéo YouTube directement et je peux
même venir naviguer ici directement dans
ma vidéo donc en fait cet écran externe
il a un vrai usage il sert réellement
quelque chose pour le calculatrice
également bref c'est pas juste un écran
de notification ici on se parle vraiment
d'un écran complet qu'on peut venir
utiliser à l'extérieur ton smartphone et
lorsque vous l'ouvrez la beauté se situe
à l'intérieur alors il y a différents
trucs qui sont intéressants notamment
par rapport à cette charnière vous
pouvez venir l'utiliser différentes
manières vous pouvez venir l'utiliser
comme ça totalement ouvert si vous le
souhaitez vous pouvez venir le plier
aussi légèrement pour l'avoir comme ça
si vous le souhaitez ou alors carrément
le plier 90 degrés le vrai usage lorsque
vous avez bien plié à 90 degrés c'est
notamment au niveau de la photo puisque
lorsque vous le pliez comme ça vous
voyez d'un point de vue logiciel ça vous
pousse la partie photo vers le haut et
ça vous donne toute une partie si
centrale avec différents raccourcis et
le truc qui est cool également c'est
voyez ici mon écran est éteint et bien
je viens appuyer juste ici et je viens
activer mon écran donc la personne qui
est en face de vous pourra se voir en
photo et si vous vous mettez en face et
bien vous verrez de la même manière
écran ouvert et vous appuyez vous
déclenchez directement pour prendre des
photos et ça aussi c'est cool et si vous
voulez le poser comme ça pour vous
filmer en face en vidéo et bien vous
pouvez le faire également très pratique
mais cet écran c'est bien plus que ça
puisqu'on est une diagonale de 6,7
pouces il est très grand c'est une dalle
P o LED Full HD+ HDR 10 plus 10 bits et
surtout avec un taux de rafraîchissement
qui va jusqu'à 144 Hertz quand je vous
parlais d'innovation ici voyez une fois
de plus on y est vous venez ici dans vos
paramètres dans vos paramètres vous
allez dans affichage et dans affichage
vous descendez jusqu'à taux de
rafraîchissement de l'écran alors vous
voyez ici c'est intéressant parce qu'il
vous le marque que vous avez uniquement
lia optimisé en automatique jusqu'à 120
Hertz mais il vous le Mac regardez juste
ici vous pouvez aller jusqu'à 144 Hertz
dans le menu jeu de l'application moto
pour les jeux compatibles ça veut dire
que si vous avez un jeu compatible qui
va être extrêmement exigeant vous pouvez
monter jusqu'à
44 Hertz alors ici c'est un écran en
vert vous avez cinq couches de vert
c'est un verre qui est très fin en fait
et vous avez surtout un écran qui 8%
plus grand par rapport à la génération
précédente est-ce que je trouve marrant
avec cette charnière c'est que vous
venez le plier facilement comme ça à une
main alors vous le pliez à une main vous
l'ouvrez également à une main vous poser
votre doigt hop tac tac on le prend le
scout et ça va très très bien et ici
Motorola nous allons jusqu'à 200000
cycles d'ouverture et de fermeture ça
c'est à vous de voir si vous voulez
passer 200000 fois comme ça le faire
vous pouvez le faire ça risque d'être
long et vous pouvez le faire absolument
et ici on a des haut-parleurs stéréo
avec Dolby Atmos voyez ça envoie du bois
quand même haut-parleur ici haut-parleur
ici en façade et haut-parleur ici sur le
côté ça dépote fort alors attention ici
on a un petit déséquilibre parce
qu'effectivement vous avez le
haut-parleur qui part de là le deuxième
haut-parleur il part de là à l'avant
donc on n'a pas exactement la même image
stéréoscopique ça ouvre quand même c'est
pas mal et on aura un peu plus de graves
ici par rapport à ici moi ce que je vous
conseille ici c'est d'utiliser néanmoins
un casque Bluetooth ça ira très bien et
ça sera beaucoup plus simple puisqu'on
se parle d'innovation on va se parler de
performance et de puissance ici Motorola
nous habite pas moins que le processeur
le plus puissant actuel sur le marché
c'est le c'est un dragon 8 plus Jane on
a 8 Go de RAM et 256 Go de stockage une
batterie de 3500 milliards avec de la
recharge turbo power la recharge rapide
en toi de ça je vous l'ai dit tout à
l'heure je vous parlais tout à l'heure
de la photo vous avez deux capteurs de
capteurs vous avez un capteur principal
c'est un 50 mégapixels c'est le capteur
grand angle l'intérêt que vous avez avec
ce capteur là c'est que vous avez la
technologie Pixel Bining en gros on
prend 4 pixels on regroupe en un seul et
même pixels ça vous fait un très gros
pixel qui va capter plus de lumière
notamment en condition de faible
luminosité ça c'est plutôt cool en plus
de ça vous avez de la stabilisation
optique et en plus de ça vous avez un
autofocus
omnidirectionnel et juste à côté vous
avez un capteur ultra grand-angle et
macro de 13 mégapixels sans oublier bien
évidemment parce qu'elle est planqué ici
une caméra de selfie de 32 mégapixels et
vous pouvez venir filmer jusqu'en 8k et
c'est permis grâce au sein dragon 8 plus
Jen 1 comme on le retrouve sur les
smartphones de Motorola ici on peut
retrouver le ready fort qui vous
permettra de transformer votre
smartphone en un petit ordinateur vous
venez l'afficher sur un moniteur et vous
aurez une expérience PC à de votre
smartphone ça c'est vachement bien si
vous avez des besoins de bureautique
sans vouloir emmener un ordinateur vous
avez votre smartphone et grâce aux
readyphore un petit clavier et une
petite souris Bluetooth vous êtes
peinard alors ici Motorola nous l'a pas
certifié IP68 IP67 donc on a absolument
aucune résistance néanmoins il nous
assure que le smartphone est
complètement étanche et que vous n'aurez
aucun problème si il se nappe le voir
pour autant on va pas le mettre dans la
piscine on va pas se baigner avec on
évite ça ne servirait à rien ça serait
bête donc on le fait pas et c'est un
smartphone qui est disponible au tarif
de
1199 € disponibles uniquement en ligne
vous pouvez le retrouver chez Motorola
et chez d'autres vendeurs et je vous
mets le lien juste en bas par la
description comment vous le trouvez vous
ce smartphone alors moi ce que j'aime
beaucoup déjà c'est le design que je
trouve très joli j'aime bien ce petit
dommage que je trouve très très cool
j'aime aussi beaucoup l'intérêt d'avoir
à cet écran à l'avant c'est vrai que
c'est un truc qui est cool et qu'on
retrouve vraiment pas partout d'avoir un
vrai écran utile si je veux garder comme
ça et si je veux pouvoir avoir des
applications connaître ma météo
rapidement si je veux avoir accès à mon
agenda rapidement si je pouvais envoyer
un SMS taper un sms ça peut paraître
bête de se dire est-ce que je vais
réussir à taper un sms parce que
regardez j'appuie ici les touches très
grosse et pourtant on y arrive regardez
coucou on se repère très très facilement
comment ça va avec un petit point
d'interrogation donc vous voyez ça se
tape bien c'est très intuitif très clair
le clavier est clair l'écran est précis
tout va bien donc ça c'est très très
chouette donc j'aime bien ça l'autre
point très positif qu'on va retrouver
ici et bien c'est le fait de quasiment
pas sentir la pliure parce qu'il n'y a
pas de pliure il n'y a pas de peinture
grâce à cette charnière en bulle d'eau
donc ça c'est pareil c'est un truc qui
est tout bête mais qui est super bien
lorsqu'on vient l'utiliser on le sent
pas donc on a une vraie belle expérience
premium sur ce Motorola Razer de 2022
comment est-ce que vous le trouvez ce
smartphone est-ce qu'il vous intéresse
qu'est-ce que vous pensez de l'évolution
de la marque on part quand même de 1928
avec un très gros point fort dans les
années 2000 et voyez Motorola est
toujours là avec l'innovation au cœur de
leur ADN donc dites-moi ce que vous en
pensez en bas dans les commentaires
est-ce que vous pourriez vous laisser
tenter et si oui je vous mets le lien en
bas dans la description je vous embrasse
prenez soin de vous on se retrouve très
bientôt pour continuer à parler tech ici
mais également ailleurs c'est chouette
bisous bisous bisous Ciao
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]